good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department i'm out here this morning to
brief you on a homicide investigation
that we are conducting on north las
vegas boulevard near the las vegas motor
speedway the details that i have right
now are very preliminary but at around
10 o'clock this morning workers who were
working along the roadway discovered the
body of a hispanic male we believed to
be between 25 and 35 years of age that
male appear was deceased when medical
personnel arrived
what we have learned at this point in
the investigation is that he is
suffering from unknown trauma we don't
specifically know until
the coroner gets here and we can remove
his clothing but it does appear that he
was dropped off here sometime in the
last several hours by a vehicle i urge
anybody who has any information to reach
out to crime stoppers
your information is completely anonymous
and there is reward money available or
you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
so again i'll take a couple questions if
you have them but it's very very early
on yes went into it that it was dropped
off but
is it being treated like a body dump
where it occurred somewhere else in this
valley we don't know where yet that is
correct at this point all indications
are that he was killed somewhere else
and uh dropped off here we just don't
have those specifics yet are there any
cameras
so right now that'll be part of our
investigation in the early stages uh we
haven't even begun the canvassing for
video but that'll be the first place we
do start
could you please give us what was his
age range again he's a hispanic appears
to be a hispanic male 25 to 35 years of
age but that's just going on a visual
estimation at this point any idea when
about he was dropped we don't we i would
say within the last eight to ten hours
would be our best guess from
an examination of the crime scene
just one more uh just to emphasize the
importance that if anybody saw anything
uh to help this investigation if
anybody's driving by even if it's at the
smallest consequence it could be helpful
yes if anybody has the smallest bit of
information if you drove by and saw
something suspicious or you have any
information that would lead to who was
responsible for this homicide please
reach out to crime stoppers thank you
guys i appreciate it thank you